[Music]
I'm Shirley
you can find me on Twitter that's me I'm
gonna share with you about UI testing
today and you guys are saying is Papa
important it's really important because
your users use your service using the
user interface duh so if you have bugs
on your users you have - - users even s
users who make less money so your
testing is really important so the UI
testing is such a pain this is what UI
testing looks like today so many devices
so many browsers Oh a day so we totally
got a automate this right but automating
UI testing is also a pain because it is
what you guys testing scripts looks like
today so that's like a popular JSI read
nightmare dodge it and spend a little
bit time
look at it it's nothing you know while
to figure out what this that's right
it's just basically going to sometime go
to fight into a search for get to search
for nightmare dodge yes well there's a
lot of code smells in this it has hard
code IDs yes matching ways it is really
the ball so he really needs to be so you
know but we can really make this make
testing a lot better so I think this is
what that should really look like I go
to dark god calm eye surgeons computer I
press the Enter key and then I see HTTP
2018 James Caan's Asia is short
this is readable this has inherent
meaning is decoupled from your UI and it
is maintainable so this is the way we
are writing our tests right now users
developers specified objects we tested
up front no we shouldn't be doing that
have the test and Geney term in their
users could what to determine objects to
test at runtime so let's make testing
create again and this is what I'm
working on is called relations and this
is a pancake so let's show you a quick
demo okay so so this is the test which
I've written on your leashes what I'm
not going here is running on Chrome and
it's time to set up the test and you'll
see the test running on the right side
here with the screenshots I will just
tell you hey it works you know I'm going
to go home and just call Asia press
Enter key and I see the result there
that's wonderful but of course these GS
called Asia we gotta see some JavaScript
right so let's do something a little bit
more complicated and try to buy some
beer from red mark so I am the list here
of beer by Chun beer and Tiger leg
appeal and the complicated thing about
read my comments that there are many
buttons they're similar to each other in
macomb such as the Add to Cart button so
if I wanna say let's add the chung-kai
cable to the case to the cart I need to
say I see
Chun tiger beer and then I add it to
cart and then when I want to add a tiger
beer
I added I do a check to see the type of
yourself first and heading to college so
we can verify that this working here so
let's go to Chun tiger view I see right
here I press Add to Cart and there you
go we have a date to the car so yellow
day we go to capisce da da we have both
the tiger vien and a champion so of
course we eat our own dog food so if you
really like the demo you can sign up and
keep your leashes
a try for free and you can go to
yahoo.com
click on sign up father you see the
green car especially in your past your
new password it press the sign up button
and we really should add we capture to
the page that's all
[Applause]
[Music]